MACH KOBAYASHI: We all want to
push the limits on our apps,
especially graphically.
But you need to be
careful out there.
Not all of your users
are going to have
the latest and greatest devices.
So what might look
great to one user
might just feel slow to another.
But you can keep
your graphics looking
awesome without
sacrificing performance
with this one weird trick.
Hi.
I'm Mach Kobayashi, and
I'm a software engineer
in Google Research.
My team is working to bring
3D objects to the world,
and I focus on the
iOS portion of that.
Let's take a look at what I've
been working on-- the newest
version of the Google
Express app for iOS.
If you're a Google
Express customer
this is the app that you
would use to buy well, just
about anything.
Now on certain items
like this camera
here, you can actually
click on the picture
and see a full 3D
view of the object.
Personally, I don't
buy any camera
until I've had a chance
to see it from the bottom.
This looks great on my
shiny new iPhone 6 Plus.
But if you were to run this on
an older device like the iPhone
4, yeah, it's a lot choppier.
It's especially
tough on this device,
because it's one of the first
with the Retina display.
Which means that it's
pushing even more pixels
than the desktop
browser version.
So what can we do
about this choppiness?
Well, let's start
by looking at how
we handle images for
the Retina display.
When Retina displays
were first released,
Apple added a content scale
factor to the UIView Class.
This content scale factor
determined how many
physical pixels represented
a logical point in a view.
By using content
scale factors, you
could represent a shape
at the exact same way
on two different devices,
even though they were made up
of drastically different pixels.
So on my iPhone 4S, the scale
factor is set to 2 by default.
For every logical
point in my view,
we're representing that as
a 2 by 2 block of pixels.
But we can actually change that.
If we take our view and reduce
the content scale factor to 1,
we now only need to supply 1
pixel for each logical point.
That means we only have to
calculate one fourth as many
pixels to cover the same area.
The device will automatically
scale things up for us
by using a crude, but
very fast technique.
Let's see this in action.
Now you can see that the
viewer is more responsive.
But can we go further?
Here I've really
exaggerated the effect
by setting content scale
factor to 0.25, which
means that we're
only calculating
164th the number of pixels
as we did originally.
In practice, there's no
need to set it this low,
but it sure is zippy.
Unfortunately, as
you can see, we're
sacrificing visual quality
for responsiveness.
So is there a way to get
the best of both worlds?
Is it possible to
switch back and forth
between different content
scale factor values?
And it turns out that you can.
What I like to do is change the
value of content scale factor
when the user begins
interacting with the object,
say, in a callback
like touches began.
Now keep in mind you'll need
to reset the frame buffer
and update your view
when you do this.
Fortunately, creating a
frame buffer is very fast,
and you can still use
your original GL context.
Now when the user stops
interacting with the object,
we can crank this
content scale factor
back up to its original setting,
and you get a high quality
picture.
So now we have a viewer
that's responsive,
but you can still show a high
quality render at the end.
We hope you found
this trick useful.
If you did, give it a
try on your own app,
and let us know in the
comments if you do.
We'd love to check it out.
I'm Mach Kobayashi for Route 85.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]